(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
♪ I know what you're doing, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ I know why you dialed my number ♪
♪ I know why you care ♪
♪ I know what you're doing, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ I know why you say you love me ♪
♪ And I don't think it's fair ♪
♪ I can recognize the symptoms ♪
♪ You should know I've changed my mind ♪
♪ I know what you're doing ♪
♪ And it's not gonna work this time ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ Said it's not gonna work this time ♪
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ I know what you're doing, baby ♪
♪ I know why you call my name ♪
♪ I know why you say you love me ♪
♪ But I can't say the same ♪
♪ I can recognize the symptoms ♪
♪ You should know I've changed my mind ♪
♪ I know what you're doing ♪
♪ And it's not gonna work this time ♪
(audience cheering and applauding)
(Kelly clapping)
- All right, everybody.
Welcome to "The Kelly Clarkson Show".
Give it up for my band, Y'all,
(audience cheering)
with "I Know" by Dionne Farris.
And give it up for our special
guest, on the keys, Jude.
Yeah.
(audience cheering)
- What's up?
- What's up, Jude?
You are so crazy talented,
I wish y'all could hear
what's happening in the
commercial breaks, y'all.
It's crazy.
We've had Jude here a couple times before,
and he's seriously incredible,
And we're gonna catch
up with Jude in a bit,
but I'm honored to have him
and all of you here today.